CAT ALLMAN: Good morning,
everybody, or good afternoon.
My name's Cat Allman.
I'm with Google's Open
Source Programs
Office here at Google.
We're happy to have with
us today Paul F. Levy.
Paul is a manager.
You might be thinking, I'm
sitting in a room, about to
listen to a manager.
But you would be wrong Paul
is a manager the way a
Stradivarius is a fiddle.
PAUL LEVY: Oh.
CAT ALLMAN: And he's
modest, too.
You can tell.
Under his leadership at the
Massachusetts Water Resources
Authority, Boston Harbor, which
had been dubbed the
dirtiest harbor in America,
was cleaned up.
He then became chair and
president of Beth Israel
Deaconess Medical Center
in Boston.
This is the teaching hospital
for Harvard University and is
consistently ranked as one of
the best hospitals in the
United States.
It was here in 2009 that he, in
the face of the recession,
worked with his employees to
crowd-source cost-savings
solutions which saved hundreds
of jobs, in particular for his
lowest-paid employees.
Here and there, he has squeezed
in serving as
chairman of the Massachusetts
Department of Public
Utilities, Executive Dean of
Administration for Harvard
Medical School.
He is a member of The MIT
Corporation and the board of
ISO New England, and he's a
20-plus-year soccer coach for
youths in the Massachusetts
area.
This man has successfully faced
down academics, hospital
administrators, and roving gangs
of 12-year-old girls.
Paul is here today to talk to us
about his book "Goal Play!
Lessons From the Soccer
Field." Please
welcome Paul Levy.
PAUL LEVY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Cat, it's really
a pleasure to be here.
I want to explain a little
bit about this
book and how it occurred.
As Cat mentioned, for over 20
years, I've been coaching
girls' soccer in my hometown,
in Newton, Massachusetts.
And during that time, I've also
had the privilege and the
luck to run a number of complex
organizations--
Beth Israel Deaconess Medical
Center, Mass Water Resources
Authority, and so on.
And what I discovered over the
20-something years of coaching
girls' soccer is that if you
can coach an 11-year-old
girls' soccer team, you can run
an academic medical center
or any other corporation.
Now I'm not sure that says
something about the emotional
energy, the emotional age of
doctors and other people with
whom you work in a hospital--
it might--
but I think it says something
more about the nature of human
beings, wherever they work
and whatever they do.
So I wrote this book, and the
book, as you'll see, consists
of a number of chapters, each
of which starts with an
anecdote about coaching girls'
soccer or refereeing soccer.
And from that, I dive into some
fairly serious lessons
about leadership.
Now I want to start by saying
that a lot of people think
about leadership in terms of the
CEO of an organization or
the president or vice president
or whatever.
And certainly those are
leadership positions.
But I think it's more important
to understand that
we are all in leadership
positions at some point in our
lives, whether at work or in
our community activities.
It might just be leading a
task force or a community
group or whatever.
It might be coaching a
girls' soccer team.
And so I would ask you to
think broadly about the
attributes that are useful to
people when you're in charge,
when you're the leader.
And I would distinguish
a little with Cat, the
difference between leadership
and manager.
A manager is someone
who manages.
A leader is someone who goes a
little further than that and
acts in a way that actually
inspires the organization or
the group of people with
whom you're working.
So you're all leaders.
You're all above
average, right?
Anybody here not above average?
Good.
This is Lake Wobegon.
I used to make a joke about my
hospital, that all the babies
born in our hospital
were above average,
at Beth Israel Hospital.
And it was true, because it
was a proposition I tested
scientifically by interviewing
grandparents.
Yeah.
And in all the years I worked
at the hospital, never once
did a grandparent say, when I
said, how's the new baby,
never once did they say, well,
kind of substandard.
It was always--
spectacular, so intelligent,
math skills, everything.
This was on day two.
And so like that, here,
you have a group
that's above average.
And in fact, you are.
I mean, we have to
acknowledge that.
This is a great place to work
and full of great people.
But like any organization, any
complex organization--
which I define as any
organization having more than
three people--
things get in the way of getting
the job done, even
though we're very
well-intentioned and above average.
So let me just dive into some
stories from the book, and
then we'll see where
they take us.
Any soccer players
here, by the way?
OK, good.
What's the most important
skill in playing soccer?
AUDIENCE: Vision.
PAUL LEVY: Vision?
Nothing?
AUDIENCE: Teamwork.
Teamwork.
PAUL LEVY: Teamwork.
Well, that's a thought--
almost.
The most important skill is
actually controlling the ball
when it gets to you.
Now why is that?
OK.
For those of you who
don't play soccer--
or football as we call
it in Mexico or
elsewhere in the world--
this is a really simple game.
There are two teams playing
on the same field.
It's a rectangle.
And at either end of the
rectangle there are goals, and
the object of the game is to
get the ball into the other
team's goal more often than
they get it into yours.
The rest, as Hillel once
said, is commentary.
Right?
That's the whole deal.
Now what makes it difficult?
And what actually makes it
similar to working for a
corporation or another
institution, is you don't know
what the other people
are planning to do
before the game starts.
You don't even know what they're
planning to do as the
game is going along, because
they're constantly changing
their strategy and their tactics
and their position
around the field.
You don't even know what the
field is going to be like
before the game starts.
Is it muddy?
Is it rutted?
Are there tufts of grass
that are going to
knock the ball awry?
You don't know what the wind is
going to be like during the
course of the game, where the
sun's going to be, whether the
clouds are going
to be covering.
Whether a dog's going to run
across the field in the middle
of the game.
You don't know what the fans
are going to be like.
You don't even know what the
referees are going to be like.
So this is a challenging
situation for your 11 players
on the field--
a constantly changing
situation.
You don't even know how your own
team is going to perform
as the game starts.
Think of the analogy
to an organization.
You're a corporation.
You're doing really interesting
things for the world.
I don't know if you've noticed
it lately, but there are
people who want to compete with
you, who have strategies,
whose whole job in life is to
figure out how to weaken you
so they can get better,
so they can score more
goals than you score.
There are things going
on internally to your
organization as well.
Was somebody sick yesterday who
was going to make a major
presentation today?
How do you adjust to that?
Does somebody in a higher-up
position here all of a sudden
decide, new strategy--
we're going that way.
How do we react to that?
So a soccer game is a wonderful
metaphor for
corporate life, because you
have both exogenous and
endogenous changes occurring
all the time.
And how do you adjust?
Well, you adjust by creating a
team that's a self-learning
organization, that can learn
in real time to make the
changes necessary to succeed.
How do you do that?
Well, you're the coach.
You're the leader of the whole
thing-- of a group, task
force, whatever.
You can't do the job.
As a coach, you're
on the sidelines.
You're advising, you're
inspiring, perhaps.
But the players on the
team are making the
decisions in real time.
So what do you need to
know, as a coach?
OK, back to our little girls.
Most important thing.
I'm talking to the 11-year-olds
one day.
These are cute little girls.
They're adorable.
They're 11.
They're feeling their oats.
They want to be good
at what they do.
They love playing soccer.
They're out there, they love
being with their friends, they
love to run around and scream.
I'm the coach, I'm the adult,
supposedly, on the field.
And I say to them, girls, you
know the most important thing
in this game is controlling
the ball as it gets to us.
Because if we don't control
it, if it bounces off our
foot, guess what?
The other team's going
to get it.
That's not good.
We want to control the ball,
so we can decide whether to
pass it, shoot it, dribble,
or whatever.
And they're nodding.
And then I say, but you know
what the most important thing
is about controlling the ball?
It's to think about what you're
going to do with it as
it approaches you.
Because you, as adults,
understand that if we wait
until the ball's at my foot,
neurologically I can't send a
signal from my brain fast enough
to deal with what that
ball is doing.
I have to think about
it as it approaches.
I don't suppose any of you
watched the baseball game last
night, but if you notice,
baseball batters, as the pitch
approaches, they actually start
swinging way before the
ball gets to them.
If they wait till it gets to
them, it doesn't work--
except for your pitcher, who
managed to slap one into left
field just at the
right moment.
So I'm saying to the girls, so I
want you to think about what
you're going to do with the ball
before it gets to you.
OK?
OK, Coach, we got it.
I say, let's try it out.
I throw a bunch of balls
out on the field.
A ball comes rolling towards
Margaret, and without thinking
about it, bam, she kicks
it into the woods.
Not even on the field
anywhere.
Into the woods.
And I say Margaret, you weren't
thinking about what
you were going to do with the
ball before it got to you.
Oh, no, Coach.
I was thinking about it.
I just hadn't reached a
conclusion, she says.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so what's the
problem here?
The problem here-- there was a
famous UCLA basketball coach
named John Wooden-- anybody
remember John Wooden, the best
coach in the world?--
who used to say, you haven't
taught it if they haven't
learned it.
You haven't taught it if they
haven't learned it.
What did he mean by that?
Well, what he meant by that is
that students, staff, are a
terrific substrate
for learning.
These are people who
want to do well.
They want to do good
for the world.
People here want to do
good for the world.
You can trust them to want to
do well and want to do good.
Your job as coach or teacher
is to help them learn what
they need to to become a
learning organization or
substantively whatever
they need.
And if they haven't learned it
and they're well-intentioned
thoughtful people, it means
you haven't taught
it the right way.
It's not their fault for
not having learned it.
It's your fault as the coach.
So what was my problem?
What did I do wrong with
this group of girls?
What do you think?
What I do wrong?
AUDIENCE: You asked them to
think rather than decide.
You asked them to think
and not decide.
PAUL LEVY: I asked them to
think, and not decide.
But how did I instruct them?
I gave them a lecture.
I engaged in didactic training
of 11-year-olds.
Think about this.
Anyone have 11-year-olds?
Anyone remember being 11?
Did you ever listen to a
lecture from a teacher?
And here I am, trying to
teach a kinesthetic
skill by giving a lecture.
Anyone take dance
lessons, ever?
Yeah.
You don't learn by a lecture,
right, Cat?
It doesn't work.
You actually have
to do the thing.
So what approach could I have
taken with these girls?
I could have said to
them, I could have
just posed the question.
I could have engaged in
a Socratic approach.
I could have said, hey, kids,
what do you think about when
the ball is rolling
towards you?
One of them probably would have
said, I'm thinking about
what I'm going to do with the
ball when it gets to me.
And then I could've said,
gee, does that
sound like a good idea?
And the others would have
said, Yeah, that's--
why?
And someone would have said,
because if you wait till it
gets to you, you muff it up.
It doesn't work well.
Oh, I'd say.
And then I could say to them,
gee, that feels like an
important thing for us
all to learn to do.
What kind of games or exercises
could you invent to
help learn how to do this?
And then they would have
invented the games.
And then we'd play the game for
a while, and I'd say, how
do we know if this is
working or not?
And then they would have
invented the metric of
success, and they would've
judged their own performance
against the metric
they invented.
They would have held themselves
accountable to the
standard of performance
that they invented.
Whoa.
What would I have
done as a coach?
I just would have asked
dumb questions.
What could we do?
Why would that work?
What else could we do?
All right.
So let's think about it from a
leadership perspective, more
broadly, now.
Your job as coach is to teach.
You're teaching lots of
different things in an
organization or on
a sporting team.
Your job is to teach.
To teach well, you have to have
some theory of learning.
If you don't have a theory of
how people learn, how do you
design your curriculum
or your pedagogy?
There's a theory of learning
that I've been using over the
years, that I borrowed from
someone at MIT, a
professor at MIT--
and she actually does machine
learning, which is really
interesting.
Nonetheless, she has this
concept of learning.
Stage one of learning.
The squeaking in the background,
by the way, is my
grandson, Liam.
He likes to sing.
Theory of learning.
Step one of learning
is interest.
This is obvious.
I decide I want to learn a
new musical instrument.
Why?
I'm interested in it.
I decide I want to learn a
different kind of computer
programming.
Some of you maybe do
that stuff here.
I'm interested in it.
Good.
Next phase after interest--
distress.
Distress.
What's distress about?
Distress is about the fact
that we are creatures of
habit, we human beings.
There's probably some
evolutionary reason for that.
I don't know.
Probably because the first time
we saw a saber-toothed
tiger, we wanted to remember
it for the next time
and the next time.
But habit gets in our way when
we're trying to learn
something new.
Why?
Because when you learn something
new, you have to
establish a new framework for
whatever it is you're trying
to learn, whether it's a
physical skill or an emotional
skill or an intellectual
skills.
Getting through that
phase is hard.
How many of you have ever felt
you've been learning something
new, and you hit a plateau?
Right?
Everybody feels that way.
What's the plateau about?
We're getting in our way of
learning the new thing.
I had a wonderful
math professor--
I was an undergraduate at MIT.
In those days, anybody
could get into MIT.
His name was Gian-Carlo Rota.
Wonderful Italian professor,
talking like
this all the time.
A lot of gestures, and so on.
By the way, what do they call
it when an Italian has a
broken arm?
A speech impediment.
So Gianco was that
kind of guy.
And he was wonderful.
He was a warm, kind man, and
a great teacher, and very
flamboyant.
And one day, he has 400 of us
in an auditorium, 400 MIT
freshmen in an auditorium, and
he's teaching us a new
theorem, and we're
not getting it.
He can see we're not getting
it, because he's looking at
our blank faces.
And so what does he do?
He tries again.
He comes around to the problem
a different way, tries a
different approach.
We're not getting it.
At this point, the rather
emotional Gianco gets upset,
angry, and he takes his chalk,
and he throws it on the
ground, and he says, look,
learning is overcoming your
prejudices.
Learning is overcoming your
prejudices, he says to us.
And we'll all go, doing!
Like this.
And we say, oh, yeah.
And we learned the theorem,
because he shocked us through.
He used the fact that we were
distressed, that we were
uncomfortable, and he
figured out a way to
push us through that.
What's the final phase after
interest, distress?
It's pleasure.
You learn the new thing,
you feel good about it.
What's your job as leader
or coach or teacher?
It's to have sufficient empathy
with the people whom
you're coaching so that you
understand where they are in
the learning process, so that
you can gently apply or
release pressure as needed.
Empathy is the most important
attribute for a leader.
Now let's think about leaders
you've known.
Let's think about coaches you've
had, and how seldom you
see empathy.
How more often, you see a highly
directive approach that
says, I'm in charge and I'm
going to tell you what to do,
and you better learn this,
and if you don't, I'm
going to blame you.
So let's approach it a different
way-- empathy.
Next phase of this whole
learning process-- oh, by the
way, in an organization, what
makes empathy interesting is
that not only do you have to
do it one-on-one, you might
have to do it with a whole
group of people, because
there's a whole coalition of
people in your organization
who are having to learn
at the same time,
at different speeds.
So that makes it complicated
and takes practice.
Let's turn now to the question
of mistakes.
Simple lesson here--
mistakes are to be cherished.
Cherished.
This is about Tova.
My daughter Sarah back there
knows Tova well.
One day, Tova, at age 28, last
year comes to me and she says,
do you remember that play
I made when we were in a
tournament in Connecticut
when I was 14?
She's 28, and she's asking
me this question.
Do you remember the play I
made in a tournament in
Connecticut when I was 14?
I said, yeah, I do.
Because I remember
every tournament.
And Tova, I said, you
made a great play.
You were the sweeper on the
field, the last defender back.
Our goalie came out, a shot
came towards the goal.
Our goalie swatted it
out into the field.
But the other team got
possession of the ball, and
someone took a shot,
point-blank, right at the
goal, and you, Tova, stood in
front of the goal and chested
the ball down and
cleared it away.
It was a great defensive play.
She says, I don't remember
that one.
I said, which one
do you remember?
She says, well, the one I
remember was, I was playing
sweeper, and a ball comes
flying towards the goal
through the air, and I tried to
head it out, and instead, I
deflected it into our goal for
the winning goal in the game
in the tournament.
I said, I don't remember
that one.
And she says, I was
devastated.
I was sitting on the grass after
the game, sobbing my
heart out, knowing that I
caused us to lose the
tournament.
And you came up to me as coach,
and you said, Tova,
don't worry about it.
You're a great defender.
I am?
I said, yeah.
Only the best defenders go out
after every single ball with a
lot of energy and intent.
And every now and then, it
deflects off of them and goes
into the goal.
Don't worry about it.
You're a great defender.
So she brushed herself off, at
age 14, walked away with her
head up high, smiling,
saying to
herself, I'm a great defender.
Now she remembered this
14 years later.
And she was paying it forward to
people in the organizations
in which she worked.
What was she paying forward?
She was paying forward the idea
that when someone has
made a mistake and is going
through a hard time, a simple
word of sympathy or empathy
can go a long way and help
them through that phase, and
help them learn from the
experience.
So how do we learn from
the experience?
We don't blame.
We don't punish.
As we like to say in the
hospital world, we want to be
hard on the problem, but
not hard on the person.
We want to say of the person,
anybody could
have made that mistake.
And indeed, as you think about
organizations, as you think
about mistakes that are made,
in general, it's true that
although a specific person may
have made the mistake, chances
are anybody could have,
in the organization.
Why?
Because most of the errors that
occur in an organization,
whether it's a hospital or a
place like this, are a result
of systemic problems in the way
work is organized in that
organization, and not because
someone is maliciously trying
to make a mistake.
I want to give you an example
from our hospital.
A patient woke up from surgery,
orthopedic surgery,
one day, looked down at her
ankle, and said, why is the
bandage on my right leg instead
of my left leg?
And it was at that moment that
her surgeon, standing right
there, realized he had operated
on the wrong ankle.
There's a technical term for
this in health care.
It's called not good.
You now can be a doctor.
You want to operate on
the correct limb.
Now this happens a
lot in the world.
In America, I think there
are two or three or four
wrong-site surgeries that
occur every week.
A lot are more serious
than the one that
this surgeon did--
wrong breasts removed, wrong
testicles removed, or in the
case of a poor guy from
Wisconsin with kidney cancer,
the wrong kidney removed.
Think about that.
How on earth can this
possibly happen?
Is it because doctors
are misanthropes who
want to hurt people?
No, in fact doctors are among
the most well-intentioned
people in the world.
They've devoted their lives to
alleviating human suffering
caused by disease.
They do not intentionally remove
the wrong breast or the
wrong testicle or the wrong
kidney, or operate on the
wrong ankle.
How does it happen?
Well, in this case, what
happened is that the surgeon
had failed to do
what's called a
time-out before the procedure.
What's a time-out?
Everybody in the OR stands
around the patient and says,
what's the name of
the patient?
What are we here to do today?
What limb are we operating on?
Is the limb marked so that we
know we're operating on the
correct limb?
He had not done that.
Why?
I'll tell you that in
a second, but he
had not done that.
So one of my trustees in the
hospital said to me, what are
you going to do to punish
this doctor?
And I said, nothing.
He said, well, you should
punish him.
He didn't follow our
time-out procedure.
And I said, look, this guy is
already feeling more distress
from his mistake and is
punishing himself more than
anything we could
ever do to him.
Why do we need to punish him?
And then a colleague of mine
said, and furthermore, if we
want to establish a culture
in this organization that
encourages people to admit
mistakes and to admit
near-misses so that we can
constantly improve as an
organization, if we start
punishing people for mistakes
that anyone could have made,
reporting will go underground.
We'll never hear about
what's going wrong.
And we don't want that.
We want to be a learning
organization.
And I said, yes, that's right.
By the way, the trustee who was
trying to get me to punish
this fellow, who said, OK, well,
if you say so, I guess
we don't want to punish him,
but in my field we would
punish him.
What field was he in?
Investment banking.
Yeah.
I don't know about you, but as
I read the newspapers, it
seems to me that when investment
bankers make
mistakes, they get bonuses.
Except in Iceland, where
they get put in jail.
But what I want to do is
describe to you the nature of
that error, to help you
understand even further why we
didn't want to punish
this guy.
So why did the surgeons
skip the time-out?
It was a procedure that he
hadn't done in a while, a
fairly complicated procedure,
on an ankle.
He had studied it before the
surgery and was rehearsing it
in his head over and over again
because he didn't want
to get it wrong.
So he was distracted by
the task at hand.
In his view, the
task at hand--
and doctors and nurses are
very task-oriented--
the task at hand was to
do the surgery right.
So I think we can forgive him
for forgetting a step along
the way, this procedural
step along the way.
What about other people
in the OR?
The anesthesiologist, in
her previous case,
had had a near miss.
She had almost administered
the wrong medication to a
patient with potentially fatal
consequences, fatal
consequences, but caught
herself in time.
And she was still stewing over
the fact that she'd almost
made that mistake.
Now if you or I made a mistake
like that, we would probably
immediately tell five
or ten people, to
get it off our chest.
Doctors don't do that.
Admitting mistakes on the part
of medical people is viewed as
a sign of weakness.
It tends to generate disdain
from their colleagues.
Even though those same
colleagues would, in their
brain, be saying, there but for
the grace of God go I. So
she kept this to herself, and
she was fretting about this as
she went into the OR.
So she forgot about
the time-out.
What about the nurse in the
OR, the circulating nurse?
The person who's supposed to
document, check the checklist
that the time-out
had taken place?
Well, the circulating nurse
had left the OR for a few
minutes to get something from
another room, had come back,
the surgery had started, and
therefore he assumed the
time-out had taken place.
So he checked the checklist.
After all, a checklist is meant
to be checked, right?
Started, check.
All right.
It gets better than that.
Gets better than that.
The correct limb was marked.
Yeah.
It was marked, but
it was draped.
Why didn't the surgeon
look for the mark?
Why didn't anybody else in
the room look for a mark?
And here we get to
a concept called
normalization of deviance.
This is a cognitive error that
occurs throughout the world.
The classic example is the
Columbia Space Shuttle.
Some of you may not
remember this.
The space shuttle, as it was
flying back to Earth, because
some heat shield tiles had come
off, burned up, killing
all aboard.
Why did that happen?
During the takeoff, some foam
from the launchpad had broken
off and had hit the
heat shield and
broken off the tiles.
Wasn't the first time, however,
that foam had broken
off during a launch.
It had happened at least
twice before.
The first time it happened,
rocket takes off, the booster
takes off, foam is
flying around.
The NASA engineers say, what's
all this foam flying around?
That's not supposed to happen.
Gee, can't figure it out.
It's not part of the
design spec, so we
can't figure it out.
But well, it doesn't seem
to do any harm.
Second time, same thing.
Takes off, foam flying around.
Third time, they discovered that
a piece of foam going 150
miles an hour has the same
amount of momentum as a cinder
block when it hits heat tiles,
ceramic tiles, and damaged the
space shuttle, burned
up coming down.
This phenomenon of accepting
defects is called
normalization of deviance.
Normalization of deviance.
Something goes wrong, we don't
see a consequence from it--
even though we know it's wrong,
we don't act to fix it
until a catastrophe occurs.
In the pre-op area in our
operating rooms, where marking
of body parts takes place, there
had been a shortage for
several months of the indelible
markers that are
used to mark body parts.
So the doctors and nurses had
gotten used to using ballpoint
pens to mark body
parts instead of
the indelible markers.
The problem with that is when
you swab Betadine on a limb
that's been marked with
a ballpoint pen, it
washes off the ink.
Surgeons had gotten used to the
idea that they would not
see a mark on the body part.
Normalization of deviance.
Isn't this fascinating?
So now who do you blame?
Who do you blame?
Everybody who was in the pre-op
area for several months
who never reported that
this was a problem?
Everybody who had marked a limb
with a ballpoint pen?
Every surgeon who had had a case
previously who didn't see
a mark, because a ballpoint
pen had been used?
Should it be the supply
department, because they
didn't provide enough markers?
So as you see, after a while,
if you go down this path,
there's nobody to blame and
everybody to blame.
But the point is, we don't
want to talk about blame.
We want to be a learning
organization.
Now how do we get to that?
We get to that by creating a
culture which enables people
on the front line, encourages
and empowers them, to call out
problems as they see them, and
requires leaders in the
organization, managers and
other leaders in the
organization, to be responsive
to those call-outs so the
problems get fixed.
And I'll end with a story about
that, that I think what
will help crystallize
it for you.
But let's go back to the
11-year-olds first.
So this is about superstars.
We had a young girl on our team
named Brooke, who was a
spectacular soccer player.
In particular, she was a
spectacular dribbler.
She could take the ball and
dribble around anything.
But the strategy of the team
was not to have a single
player dribble down the field.
The strategy of the team is to
pass to one another, because
even a great player is going
to hit opposition from
opposing players.
And the way you get down the
field is you pass the ball to
your teammates.
When someone's open, you pass to
them, and you get the ball,
and you pass again.
Now, Brooke understood this,
and she was a great team
player and very unselfish, would
always pass the ball to
other teammates, just the
way she was supposed to.
And our team had a spectacular
record.
Well, on this particular day,
we were playing in a
tournament-- these are
11-year-olds--
and the team against which we
were playing wasn't as good as
we were, and so they packed
the defense on the field.
They put all their players right
in front of the goal.
So our normal practice of going
down the field-- pass,
pass, pass, shoot--
wasn't working because they
would block the shot.
There were just too many
of them in the way.
And our girls were getting
really frustrated, and at
halftime, it was 0-0.
And it's a tournament game.
You gotta win in tournaments.
So in front of all the girls,
I say to Brooke, Brooke,
you're a spectacular dribbler,
and normally, I want you to
pass to other players.
It's part of our
team approach.
But just this once, next time
you get the ball, just walk it
into the goal.
She says, what do you mean?
Slight grin appearing
on her mouth.
I said, get the ball, dribble
through those other players,
and just score.
OK, Coach, she says.
I can do this.
So we start up, she gets the
ball on the 35-yard line.
Doot-doot-doot-doot-doot.
Scores.
I mean, it took 10 seconds.
High fives from the
whole team, right?
Now if Brooke had usually
played that way, there
would've been a lot
of resentment.
But because the whole team
understood it was part of the
strategy to use the attributes
of our superstar, it was
acceptable.
It was more than acceptable.
It was great.
So lesson one, here.
Every organization
has superstars.
It's fine to use their
attributes that are different
from other people,
as long as it's
part of the team strategy.
Lesson two-- a little
more subtle.
We can find superstars
everywhere in the
organization.
Every single person in a place
like this has certain
characteristics, skills, or
attributes that are different
from other people, that can be
brought to bear to carry out
the purposes of the organization
if we give that
person the freedom to
offer those skills.
I want to tell you about Gloria
Martinez, in our hospital.
Gloria was a transporter.
A transporter is one of the
lowest-paid jobs in the hospital.
It's an entry-level job.
Transporters push beds around,
and wheelchairs with patients,
delivering them from one place
to the other, and also deliver
specimens from the various
departments to the pathology
lab to be analyzed.
This is like a no-brain
operation, right?
I pick it up, I walk
over, I deliver it.
Gloria, one day, noticed that
specimens from our GI
department were not
getting delivered
consistently to the path lab.
They would be lost
occasionally.
And she took it upon herself to
tell her supervisor about
this, because she figured it
was important for those
specimens to be delivered.
Now those of you of a certain
age who've had colonoscopies--
and the rest of you
will someday.
This is a wonderful procedure
you'll really get to enjoy--
know that the idea of a
colonoscopy is to take a look
at your colon from the inside,
and if the doctor sees a polyp
growing on the inside of your
colon, she clips it off, and
they send it to the lab, because
they want to know if
it's cancerous or
precancerous.
In today's world, we can
actually eliminate colon
cancer by this kind of
early detection.
So if a sample gets lost on the
way to the path lab and
someone is not diagnosed with
precancerous polyps or
cancerous polyps, a year or two
later, they're going to
have colon cancer.
So it's an important test.
And Gloria, maybe not knowing
why it was important,
understood that it was important
for these samples to
get delivered.
And so when they weren't getting
delivered, she called
out this problem to
her supervisor.
Now I don't want to stereotype
here, but let me tell you
about Gloria.
Gloria is a recent immigrant
from Latin America.
Her primary language
is Spanish.
The family is not well-off.
She's a high school-educated
person.
I would suggest to you that
it's highly likely--
I've met her family-- it's
highly likely that her large
extended family of cousins and
uncles and aunts and parents
and grandparents does not say
to Gloria every day when she
goes to work, make sure you find
something wrong in the
work environment and make
a fuss about it.
No.
More likely they say to her,
you're lucky to have a job.
Keep your head down.
But Gloria felt comfortable,
because of the culture we had
established in our hospital,
calling out this problem.
Her supervisor, her leader,
her coach, had also been
trained so that when Gloria
called out the problem, he
said in a kind, pleasant way--
he did not say, I'm
busy right now.
Tell me about it later.
No, he said, thank you
so much, Gloria,
for mentioning this.
This is important.
We're going to get on it.
And as a result of her call-out,
that one time, we
totally revamped the way
specimens were tracked and
collected in our hospital.
Gloria, personally, probably
saved some lives.
She may have saved as many
lives as some of the GI
doctors, if you think
about it.
Around this time, we had created
what we call our
Caller-Outer of the
Month award.
This was an award from our
Board of Trustees to
acknowledge someone in
the company who had
called out a problem.
Not solved a problem, but called
out a problem, because
we want to encourage
these call-outs.
Gloria gets the first award,
which is a letter from me and
two tickets to Fenway Park
to watch the Red Sox.
That's a baseball team we
have on the other coast.
Although this year, they really
weren't a baseball team.
They were something else.
Yeah, they were awful.
They were awful.
It was over by July 4.
So here's Gloria, getting
this award.
Imagine her, 23 years old, her
background, her not-so-good
English, getting an award from
the suits, the people on the
board, the real estate
people, the
attorneys, the finance people.
It's pretty intimidating.
We give her the award,
and she says the
following, in these words.
Thank you so much for this
award, which I accept on
behalf of all of the
transporters who work here,
who believe that our job is to
deliver the kind of care to
patients that we would want for
members of our own family.
I had board members crying
when she said that.
Why?
Because she had codified
elegantly, in one sentence,
the purpose of our hospital,
that all those board members
were volunteering their time and
effort and money for, to
create an institution that would
deliver the kind of care
to any patient that you
or I would want for a
member of our family.
And Gloria got it.
For me, it was one of the most
satisfying days working in
that hospital.
Why?
Because it indicated that the
cultural change we had made in
the hospital, in terms of
everybody feeling ownership
with regard to the purpose of
the organization, feeling
empowered to call out problems,
to make suggestions,
and to have a leadership team
in the organization that was
responsive to those call-outs,
had succeeded.
It was a wonderful moment.
So let me stop there with
stories, and we can take some
questions or observations.
Let me just summarize.
Let's think about it.
Your job as leader,
you're the coach.
Your job is to help people
learn, to create a learning
organization that can respond
to whatever's going on,
internally and externally.
To think about that learning
cycle of interest, distress,
and pleasure.
To have empathy for people as
individuals and groups of
people, to help them through
the learning cycle.
To cherish mistakes--
not to blame people for
mistakes, to help them through
the mistakes and to help them
learn from the states.
And then finally, to recognize
that everybody
is a potential superstar.
We don't have to do
a draft choice.
Who's our recruiter
over there?
We don't have to do
a draft choice.
Everybody can contribute
to the purpose of the
organization.
But fundamentally to understand
that your job as
leader is to believe that the
people with whom you're
working want to do well in their
job and want to do good
for the world, and that you can
trust them, that they will
actually hold themselves
accountable to a standard of
performance and care and
diligence in a much more vital
and real way than you
can ever hold them
accountable as their leader.
You can't do it from the top.
They have to feel
it internally.
They will feel it internally if
you create an environment
that allows them to do
what they want to do
in the first place--
to do well, and to do good.
OK.
I'm going to stop right
there, and see if
there are any questions.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about empathy.
You talked about that in
leadership it's important to
have empathy to everyone.
But there is also a leadership
style that says about a
healthy mixture of fear and
respect is also needed.
What are your thoughts
on that?
PAUL LEVY: Well some leaders
do rule through fear.
And it can be extremely
effective.
And an organization can do
all right for some time.
Generally, though, you'll find
that the organization will not
do well for a long period of
time or when there are
structural changes that occur
in that industry.
And the reason for that is
no single person can be
knowledgeable enough to
anticipate all those changes
and to design where
the organization
should go in the future.
No one is good enough.
The Soviet Union used to try
to, you know, the Politburo
used to try to run the Soviet
economy from on high.
It works for a while, but it
doesn't work after a while.
The best ideas in an
organization tend to come from
people on the front line who
notice a problem or notice
that a competitor is doing
something else, and says, you
know, maybe we should do
something about that.
So it can work for a while.
Some people like it.
By the way, some people like
working in an environment
where the boss is heavy-handed
and makes them fearful.
And some people like being in
a marriage or a relationship
where there's an abusive
relationship as well.
It takes all types.
I don't particularly like that,
and I think most people
don't respond that way.
And I certainly think that most
professional people--
highly-educated, intelligent,
thoughtful people--
do not like that at all.
The reason they're professional
people is because
they have enough sense of self
that they think they can
self-motivate, and they can.
AUDIENCE: There are people who
intentionally make mistakes,
or who intentionally
do bad things.
So what do you do when you catch
those people who are
outliers, maybe?
PAUL LEVY: Yeah.
So there are people who
intentionally make mistakes
and cause damage.
I would suggest to you, first
of all, it's a very, very,
very small percentage.
Most people are not misanthropes
and jerks.
Most people are like
you and me.
We want to do well, we want to
do good, and when we make a
mistake, we tend to feel badly
about it, and we hope not to
do it again.
If you believe that someone
really intentionally is
sabotaging an organization or
a team or whatever out of
negligence or intent, real
intent, they really want to
destroy it?
Get rid of them.
Zero tolerance for that.
As I say, very small
percentage.
I think what you'll find,
though, most of the time when
people are not performing in a
job, that it relates to one of
a few things.
The most common problem I've
seen when people make a
mistake or are not performing
in a job, the most common
problem is that something's
going wrong at home.
They're having a problem with
a sick relative, a spouse, a
child, whatever it is.
And they can't get it out of
their mind and they're not
focused correctly
on their work.
And our job, at that point, is
to help them through that,
just as you would
help a friend.
Problem number two.
They don't really know what
to do in the job.
They don't have the skills.
Why?
Well, maybe we haven't
trained them enough.
There was a nurse in Brazil who
made a fatal mistake in a
clinic in Rio de Janeiro.
She's now being tried for
involuntary manslaughter.
The problem, the real problem
was, she wasn't trained
properly for the procedure
she was told to do.
She actually did not
know that she was
incompetent to do that procedure.
Whose fault is that?
Is that her fault?
I don't think so.
I think it's her
leader's fault.
So the second category of
problems, if somebody doesn't
know how to do the job right,
let's train them.
It might be, however, that
they're not trainable in that
particular skill.
And we have to admit that
some people are not.
I mean, I'm never going to be
a Major League baseball
pitcher, no matter how many
times I would try.
Let's move them to
a different job.
Let's find a job that is
more suited to their
characteristics, their skills,
their aptitudes.
Sometimes there's a problem in
the work environment in which
somebody is placed, that they're
not getting along with
other people or with their
supervisor, or whatever.
That's a difficult problem that
requires some counseling,
of everybody, usually.
And then once you get through
that whole list--
I would say that's 95%
of the cases--
then in a very small amount of
cases, this person really
shouldn't be here.
Not because they're a
misanthrope or a jerk, but
they're just not suited
to the place.
And then we should ask
them to leave.
As often as not, I've found
that when it gets to that
point, the person is so relieved
to leave that they
feel like you're doing
them a favor.
So that's my take on that.
Thanks for raising it.
AUDIENCE: For the most part I
think it's true that people
prefer kind of an egalitarianism
an autonomous
work environment.
But they've also shown
that there's kind of
like a sliding scale.
So in very stressful situations
or when things kind
of take a turn for the south,
people actually prefer
aggressive leaders,
top-down leaders.
So I'm wondering, in your
personal experience, how to
recognize that point, and if you
have any personal examples
of when you've had to kind of
change from the egalitarian,
empathetic model to more of a
top-down, you're the leader--
PAUL LEVY: I actually have not
found that to be the case.
I know people talk about
it that way.
But we had an example
in our hospital--
Cat talked about it briefly.
During 2009, the economy
tumbled.
Revenue to our hospital went
through the floor.
Instead of projecting a $20
million loss, by halfway
through the year we
were projecting--
I mean a gain.
By halfway through the year,
we were projecting a $20
million loss.
So a $40 million shift
in six months.
My CFO and COO came to
me and said, we need
to lay off 400 people.
That's how we have to
solve this problem.
And I said, no, I'd
rather not.
Let's talk to folks and see
what ideas we could get to
solve this problem.
And they looked at me like I was
crazy, and they said, no,
you don't understand.
We need to act quickly.
We need to identify the people,
and-- this was March
1-- by April 1, have
it in place.
Because we're losing hundreds
of thousands
of dollars per week.
And I said, well, let's
just give it a try.
So what did I do?
I called people together
in town meetings.
I had the CFO explain the
financial situation in about
five minutes.
And then I said to the
staff, look, we have
some options here.
One is I could assert authority
and eliminate a
number of hundreds of
positions here.
The other thing we could do is
together decide on sacrifices
that we would all take, small
sacrifices we would all take
to solve this problem.
Whether it's pay cuts or freezes
or whatever it is or
other things, I'd rather do
that, because we're in the
middle of a recession
right now.
The unemployment rate
was about 8%.
If I fire one of you, it's going
to be really hard for
you to get another job.
And at an 8% unemployment rate,
statistically one in 12
of your spouses is currently out
of work, and I don't want
to create non-working
families.
So what do you say about us
coming together and coming up
with ideas?
And they're nodding and they're
smiling, they're
feeling good about it.
And then I say to them, I also
want to run another idea by
you to see what you
think about it.
There are people in
this hospital--
the transporters, the food
service workers, the
housekeepers--
who don't earn very much
money to start with.
What would you think about the
idea of exempting them from
any of the sacrifices the rest
of us take, understanding that
it means that everybody else
is going to have to take a
slightly bigger sacrifice to
compensate for those several
hundreds of people.
The room burst into applause.
Burst into applause.
It was a very moving moment.
So what do we do?
So we set up chat rooms, I have
my blog, I have email,
I've been walking around
town meetings.
And I said, send
me your ideas.
Send me your ideas.
And so I got thousands
of ideas.
The book tells you
how many we got.
And then a week or so later, I
put out a memo, an email to
the staff, saying, here are the
major ideas I've received.
Here's how they would
work or not work.
Here's a smaller group that
I'm considering for the
future, that I'll decide upon.
Let me know what you
think about those.
They commented on those, and
then a week or so later, I put
out the final memo, saying,
OK, here's what
we're going to do.
Thanks for your suggestions.
I couldn't adopt all of
your suggestions.
In adopting a suggestion or
not adopting one of your
suggestions, it doesn't mean
that I didn't think
you had a good idea.
It just means that my final
responsibility here is to make
the final decisions on this.
And I have to feel comfortable
in the ones I've chosen.
Here is what I've done.
We avoided the layoffs.
Avoided the layoffs.
Then the other thing I did is,
I did just a SurveyMonkey
thing a few weeks later, saying
OK, if we start to get
better here financially, which
of the things would you like
restored first, as it's
possible to do that?
And I took the results of that
survey, and as the economy
improved and our hospital got
better, I'd send out a note
like four months later.
Oh, things are better, we can
now restore the 401(k) match.
Thanks very much.
That was the first
on your list.
Three months later, it'll
be the next thing.
And after about eight months,
we were doing so much better
that I actually give everybody
in the hospital a $500 bonus.
So there's the situation.
I mean, this was a high-stress
situation.
When a hospital loses money,
it's not good.
Because our only source
of money is
what we actually earn.
And I could've taken the
hierarchical approach.
People would have accepted it.
They would have said, well, he
has to do what he has to do.
But think of what we
would have lost.
First of all, 400 people
wouldn't have had jobs.
Secondly, we would have lost
the opportunity to come
together as a community--
or as we said, as a family--
to make this thing work, and
in essence, to take care of
ourselves in the same way we
took care of patients.
So it was a huge morale boost
for the organization.
Plus because people had
participated in the selection
process, they bought
into them.
They said, well, this is
the right way to do it.
Now around this time, I was
speaking to a president of a
major university that was going
through a similar period
and suggested to this person
that this university might
adopt a similar approach.
And the response of this
president was, well,
participation is one thing.
Pandemonium is another.
That was the view.
My own board chair said to me,
you know, I wouldn't have had
the nerve to do what you did.
And I said to him, Steve, why
does this take any nerve?
I mean, I'm asking advice.
I'm getting participation.
I'm making the final decision,
but I'm engaging people.
And by the way, many of them
will come up with ideas that I
hadn't thought of.
And he said, yeah, but I
wouldn't have had the nerve to
do that my firm-- he was a
managing partner somewhere.
It would have felt like
losing control.
And I said, well, any feeling
that you have control is a
mirage to start with.
You don't.
No one controls this place.
I know the founders of this
organization might feel that
way, from time to time.
But they would admit privately,
I think, that they
don't have control, either.
What do you have, 60,000
people now?
Something like that?
No one controls this place.
No, no.
You know that.
No one even controls your own
division, even if you've got a
pretty hierarchical kind
of management.
No, no.
You control what you
do every day.
And what makes you good at what
you do institutionally is
that you take on that
responsibility, you feel a
sense of engagement, creativity,
and purpose, and
you do stuff that helps to
satisfy the corporate mission.
That's what we want
to have there.
So I would say to you, when
in doubt, back off.
Ask everybody what they think.
The worst that happens
is they don't come up
with any good ideas.
But you've asked.
The best that happens is they've
come up with great
ideas, they're there to help you
implement them, you make
them feel good, they
solve your problem.
It's not bad.
All right.
Are we at the end of
our allotted time?
CAT ALLMAN: Yeah.
PAUL LEVY: Thank
you very much.
It's a pleasure.
Oh, let me just say, of course
I'm on Facebook, Twitter,
LinkedIn, all those things.
I have a wonderful blog.
It used to be called "Running
a Hospital." It's now called
"Not Running a Hospital."
And I'd love to have
you be in touch in
any way in the future.
And for those of you who want
to hang around for a few
minutes, I'm happy to
sign your book.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]